j'aurais dû prendre mes raquettes
pourquoi les gens mettent ce qui est
très marrant c'est que bien que ce soit
une vieille tradition ça reste l'un des
moyens les plus efficaces de marché sur
la glace soit je crois que vous allez
vous plaira biver field
[Musique]
chaque personne qui vit à quelque chose
d'un peu suspect un jab pas être contre
les habitants
et le mauvais temps
total
[Musique]
aux
honneurs en fait une tête on dirait que
vous avez vu un cadavre les routes sont
en piteux état nous avons un problème
avec le générateur qu'elle générateur
ils sont tous en panne j'arrive pas à
aller sur internet
juliet on a aussi un cadavre sous le
porche
c'est probablement un loup est devenu un
spécialiste des loups marcus allez
savoir où et quand il remettra ça et qui
sera sa prochaine victime
je crois qu'on est tous d'accord pour
dire que le danger rita l'extérieur
qu'il convient de rester groupé
simplicité qui porte une arme
alors c'est parti pour la soirée pyjama
avec des flingues avec des flingues les
méthodes de ce prédateur sont récents
cueillir ce n'est pas un humain ce n'est
pas un canidé mais c'est l'un d'entre
eux ce serait quoi ah les lycanthropes
quoi à l'e3 était un loup garou
il aurait pu y entrer
sorti plus tôt
dit qu'il était sorti
c'est peut-être moi le loup garou
c'est peut-être toile de 40
tm garde
camille qu'un
camion peut-être connaître tous les
loups garous
c'est quoi le topo on se retrouve dans
une impasse mexicaine du jury ont eu
beau mexicaine c'est une impasse tout
court
elle est sûrement déjà ouvertes
logiquement elle devrai suffit de vous
essayer de sortir savoir innover pour
ses systèmes de sécurité qui vend
ses plaies et
bosses on vous apprenait hier j'aurais
très bien privé
[Musique]